now that we know the power rule and we
saw that in the last video that the
derivative with respect to X of X to the
N is going to be equal to n times X to
the n minus 1 for n not equal 0 I
thought I would expose you to a few more
rules or concepts or properties of
derivatives it essentially will allow us
to take the derivative of any polynomial
so this is powerful stuff going on so
the first thing I want to think about is
why this little special case for n not
equaling 0 what happens if N equals 0 so
let's just think of the situation let's
try to take the derivative with respect
to X of X to the 0 power well what is X
to the 0 power going to be well and we
can assume that X for this case right
over here is not equal to 0 0 to the 0
weird things happen at that point but if
X does not equal 0 what is X to the 0
power going to be well this is the same
thing as the derivative with respect to
X of 1 X to the 0 power is just going to
be 1 and so what is the derivative with
respect to what with the derivative with
respect to X of 1 and to answer that
question
I'll just graph it I'll just graph f of
X equals 1 to make it a little bit
clearer so that's my y-axis this is my
x-axis and let me graph y equals 1 or f
of x equals 1 so that's 1 right over
there F of x equals 1 it's just a
horizontal line so that right over there
is the graph y is equal to f of X which
is equal to 1 now remember the
derivative one way to conceptualize it
is just the slope of the tangent line at
any point so what is the slope of the
tangent line at this point and actually
what's the slope at every point well
this is a line so the slope doesn't
change has a constant slope and it's
completely horizontal line it has a
slope of 0 so the slope at every point
over here slope is going to be equal to
0 so the slope of the the slope of this
line at any point is just going to be
equal to 0
and that's actually going to be true for
any constant the derivative if I had a
function
ad f of X is equal to 3 let's say that
that's Y is equal to 3 what's the
derivative of Y with respect to X going
to be equal to and I'm intentionally
changed showing you all the different
ways of the notation for derivative so
what's the derivative of Y with respect
to X it can also be written as Y prime
what's that going to be equal to well
it's the slope at any given point and
you see that no matter what X you're
looking at the slope here is going to be
0 so it's going to be 0 so it's not just
X to the 0 if you take the derivative of
any constant you're going to get 0 so
let me write that derivative with
respect to X of any constant so let's
say that of a where this is just a
constant where this is just going to be
a constant that's going to be equal to 0
so pretty straightforward idea now let's
explore a few more properties let's say
our 2t I want to take the derivative
with respect to X of let's use the same
a let's say have some constant times
some function times some function well
derivatives work out quite well you can
actually take this this little scalar
multiplier this little constant and take
it out of the derivative this is going
to be equal to a it's going to be equal
to a I don't want to do that in magenta
color it's going to be equal to a times
the derivative of f of X a times the
derivative of f of X the blue color of f
of X and the other way to denote the
derivative of f of X is to just say that
this is the same thing this is equal to
a times this thing right over here is
the exact same thing as f prime of X now
this might all look like really fancy
notation but I think if I gave you an
example it might make some sense so what
about if I were to ask you the
derivative with respect to X the
derivative with respect to X of 2 of 2 x
times X to the fifth power
well this property that I just
articulated says well this is going to
be the same thing as two times the
derivative this is going to be the same
thing as two times the derivative of X
to the fifth two times the derivative
with respect to X of X to the fifth
essentially I could just take this
scalar multiplier and put it in front of
the derivative so this right here this
is the derivative with respect to X of X
to the fifth
and we know how to do that using the
power rule this is going to be equal to
two times let me write that I want to
keep it consistent with the colors this
is going to be two times derivative of X
to the fifth well the power rule tells
us n is five is going to be 5 X to the 5
minus 1 or 5 X to the fourth power so
it's going to be 5 X to the fourth power
which is going to be equal to 2 times 5
is 10 X to the fourth so 2 X to the
fifth you can literally just say okay
the power rule tells me the derivative
of that is 5x to the fourth 5 times 2 is
10 so that simplifies our life a good
bit we can now using the power rule and
this one property take the derivative of
anything that takes the form ax to the N
power now let's think about another very
useful derivative property and these
don't just apply to the power rule they
apply to any derivative but they are
especially useful for the power rule
because it allows us to construct
polynomials and take the derivatives of
them but if I were to take the
derivative of the sum of two functions
so the derivative of let's say one
function is f of X and then the other
function is G of X it's lucky for us
that this ends up being the same thing
as the derivative of f of X plus the
derivative of G of X so this is the same
thing as F actually let me use that
derivative operator just to make it
clear it's the same thing as the
derivative with respect to X of f of X
plus the derivative with respect to X of
G of X so we put f of X right over here
and put G of X put G of X right over
there and so with the other notation we
could say this is going to be the same
thing derivative with respect to X of f
of X we can write as f prime
of X and the derivative with respect to
X of G of X we can write as G prime of X
now once again this might look like kind
of fancy notation to you but when you
see an example it'll make it pretty
clear if I have if I want to take the
derivative with it with respect to X of
let's say X to the third power plus X to
the negative 4 power this just tells us
that the derivative of the sum is just
the sum of the derivatives so we can
take the derivative of this term using
the power rule so it's going to be 3x
squared + 2 that we can add the
derivative of this thing right over here
so it's going to be + that's a different
shade of blue + and over here is
negative 4 so it's plus negative 4 plus
negative 4 times X to the negative 4
minus 1 or X to the negative 5 power so
we have and I can just simplify a little
bit this is going to be equal to 3 this
is going to be equal to 3x squared - 4 X
to the negative 5 and so now we have all
the tools we need in our toolkit to
essentially take the derivative of any
polynomials so let's give ourselves a
little practice there so let's say that
I have let's say that I have and I'll do
it in a I'll do it in white let's say
that f of X is equal to 2 X to the third
power minus 7x squared plus 3x minus 100
what is f prime of X what is the
derivative of F with respect to X going
to be well we can use the properties
that we just said the derivative of this
is just going to be 2 times the
derivative of X to the third derivative
of X to the third is going to be 3x
squared so it's going to be 2 times 3x
squared what's the derivative of
negative 7x squared going to be what's
going to be negative seven times the
derivative of x squared which is 2x 2x
what is the derivative of 3x going to be
what's just going to be 3 times the
derivative of X or 3 times the
derivative of X to the first the
derivative of X to the first is just 1
so this is just going to be plus 3 times
we could say 1 X to the 0 but that's
just 1 and then finally what's the
derivative of a constant going to be let
me do that in a different color what's
the derivative of a constant going to be
well we cover that at the beginning of
this video the derivative of any
constant is just going to be 0 so plus 0
and so now we are ready to simplify the
derivative is of F is going to be 2
times 3 x squared is just 6 x squared
negative 7 times 2x is negative 14x plus
3 and we don't have to write the zero
there and we're done we now have all the
properties in our tool belt to find the
derivative of any polynomial and
actually things that even go beyond
polynomials